climate change a highly anticipated UN
climate change report out this morning
raises the alarm about the world's
oceans more than a hundred scientists
spent the last three years looking at
the impact of climate change on glaciers
and the seas Mark Phillips is in Monaco
forest where the findings were released
mark what we learned good morning well
this report concerns the world's oceans
and frozen regions in other words the
North and South Poles and mountaintops
its general conclusions they can't take
it anymore the consequences for Humanity
severe until now much of the Earth's
warming has been absorbed in its oceans
but according to this latest UN report
tipping points are being reached where
some of the more severe consequences of
climate change can no longer be avoided
melting ice in Greenland Antarctica and
from mountain glaciers is continuing at
accelerating rates and the resulting
sea-level rise around the world already
threatens coastal populations in the
worst case scenarios as many as a
billion people could be affected it may
all sound like doomsday but one of the
authors of the report Arizona climate
scientist had sure says the signs of it
are already happening
looking at the time that those events
that happen one in a hundred years
happen once a year and you can relate to
something like that where exactly
imagine imagine you have a story that
your grandfather told you about you know
the town flooding but it was back eighty
years ago well imagine that happening
every year the report lists a cascade of
potential negative effects for more
severe storms to droughts to declining
fish stocks and the more we continued to
pump carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
the more catastrophic those effects may
be
the report's authors say that we are now
in a race between the speed of climate
change and our ability to adapt to it
and that it's a race that we're losing
it's no longer a question of if or when
the consequences will happen but how bad
they will be Tony frightening new
details Mark Phillips forests in Monaco
mark thank you very much